[Music]
okay thanks for coming and welcome to
our data what is he okay I'm sorry
my name is Ricardo fawful and I have
been working in the new let go data
platform for the last two years
let hall is a second-hand market place
with more than 100 million other laws
and more than 400 million of listings
the amount of data that flows in let-go
platform is huge for example our users
has same between each other over seven
billion on messages science let go
launched in 2015 7 billion is like each
person in the planet has sent a message
with us some numbers of our platform are
1 billion of misrata bans process daily
peak of more than 50,000 events per
second more than 600 event types 200
terabytes of data in our data lake a
most important we process this event in
near real time with latencies under one
second the road wasn't easy we started
as many other started with limited
resources and a few users our
architecture start with a traditional bi
architecture we have a business
analytics team competing for scarce
resources
at first we secured our queries again
MariaDB then we move to maria de Vere's
life and as usual the nest egg was a set
of ETL process
with the aim of copying data from
MariaDB to recive although the problem
kappa period every day we have a growing
number of users and new members joining
the bi team as a result we have we
started having a scalability problems in
addition we began to have more and more
complex use cases so for all of that the
traditional bi architecture didn't meet
our requirement we needed something new
this wasn't only a data problem
or let go faced with similar scalability
problem so we decided to move from a
monolithic architecture to an
architecture based on micro services and
events so how to develop and even driven
data architecture the first step is to
understand what uneven is we have two
kind of event tracking event represent
the user interactions into the app for
example the user visit a product or the
user make assert and domained event at
those event that capture the memory or
something interesting for let go for
instance a user has been registered or a
product has been published these are the
three stages of our talk we will tell
from the data recollection until the
data exploitation the first one is to
ingest in let go all our team published
domain events into SNS channels and then
we can subscribe sqs chat accused to
these channels our goal was to move this
event to a more data friendly broker in
the end we choose Kafka we try multiple
option for for the start with Rui Apache
flume flu Andy Kafka res proxy also
kinases will fire horse but none of this
alternative combines us i watch a talk
about calf cocoon 8 and everything
fitted with our idea calf cocoon 8 has
all the goofing off
and a part of that comes with dozen of
connectors but what is a connector calf
cocoon it has two connector times types
so they allow us to read through an
external component unpublished event
into into Kafka while others are sings
they allow us to really bend from Kafka
unpublished events to external component
we started with an open sore sqs
connector but it didn't read the
performer that we need you know it only
process around 1,000 event per second
and we need it much more so we have to
create a custom connector and it was
really easy to write a custom connector
you need to implant you only need to
implement a few classes and all the
difficult things are done by kafka
cüneyt framework with outstanding
performance I'm sorry it's not working
this was the moment and changed
everything
now everything that happened in let go
is a story in real time into Kafka so we
can start thinking about how to process
this event our journey to the start
begins ok
the first step is how to build the data
like we want to store our event into a
stream and keep them forever
in order to use them later we try to
options
Kafka conet and spark but in order to
justify our choose we have to talk about
some problems because the wall is not
perfect and sometimes it happens our
architecture ensure that we never loose
events however duplicating events will
happen for the reason we decided to use
Cassandra for the duplicate our event we
can write several times the same event
into Cassandra but because it's not my
event contains a unique identifier in
the end Cassandra we only have one copy
of the event so we have achieved our
decided web application after that we
only need to read event from from
Cassandra and write them into s3 as raw
event and also as imported format in
order to optimize our analytical queries
the next problem that we face is that
sometimes the band arrive late hours
even days later consequently if we only
read events from Cassandra and write
them into s3 we could lose some very
late events some companies repeat this
process with difference intervals of
time one hour one day later but in this
way
we could always lose some very late
events so with a sign at a solution that
we call dirty bucket but what is dirty
bucket first we read event from Kafka
and right then into s3 into Cassandra
but in this step for each combination
between event type our we publish a
domain event we publish a domain event
into a compact Kafka drop a topic
so now this part job only needs to read
from this topic in order to know which
combination between even type our soul
we process the job read events the
required events from Cassandra and
finally write them into s3 without the
possibility of losing events there are
also some problems with s3
since s3 and hdvs are different with
faced with eventual consistency and
various law remains you might face with
this error your job start writing in
history and suddenly you receive an odd
phone hero the reason of this hero is
has three eventual consistency your job
right through some node in history and
then try to write read the file again
but another no dot s3 without the file
received the request as a result s3
return an error luckily we can use as
regard to handle this problem both in
closer and in Horton Wars s3 bar Wars
login all the metadata metadata chains
made in history to external consistency
a store at name the metadata stored
since metadata storage is consistent as
three I can use it to fill the missing a
state not yet visible in a3 have you
have you write a job that writes a lot
of data into s3 that in the end look
like his frozen it doesn't have any
active tags but it is still running what
is happening in order to maintain the
consistency of data in case of failure
Esper write the data to a temporal
folder and all in the last last step
move the data to its final location
this happens instantly in a TPS however
in history is a very time-consuming
operation because moving a file in s3
means copying the file and then deleting
the other one this is not convenient
when you war with big files and his
polls is a nice Wars when you war with
many fails the way to address this
problem is to use the new STI committers
let go we tried the magnetometer now
everything that happened in that role is
asteroid in Africa in real time we have
built our data leg and now it's time to
think about how to make data processing
there are two ways to make data
processing a streaming and batching
let's start with the streaming Allegro
we have several apps running in the
streaming but we are going to talk about
two of them the first one real-time user
segmentation we want to classify we want
to classify our users in real-time so
for that we create an app using a cast
win the process all the behavioral event
with a sign it using event sourcing and
these are the stages that happen in the
processing of a given first of all we
have to restore the user state really
need from the snapshot and a journal
then rewrite the new event into the
urinal and finally we apply the rule
publish Sina the main event in K in case
of a new user state has been detected
let go uses this event to change its
behavior for example the notification
sent by let go or the result so in the
field depends on the user state the
second sample is our users also interact
between each other
this are the typical question that
happens in a conversation between them
but for us was very difficult to
understand what happened in a
conversation and we want to improve our
user experience the solution was a
structured data we send messages that a
machine can understand our idea our
first idea was to improve the proposal
of medians the the user
the user click on a bottom select a
place to meet between a list of
suggested place select the time and
finally search the proposal and the
other user and the other user received
the proposal in a nice interactive
widget accepting or rejecting the
proposal
go to the tab this pattern
welcome to complex even processing a
technology that you can use in case that
you need to the tab pattern between
events with this technology you can
detect things like a meeting proposal
followed by a meeting a set that means
meeting a schedule and we publish at the
main event a represented match or a
meeting proposal not followed by an
answer within our day we can detect this
pattern and publish' do my event you
have a pending proposal as part doesn't
have this technology so for this use
case we'll have to use a batch of link
another word typical uses of steps are
flock detection and real-time user
recommendations the next step in our
journey is batching what seems to be the
most important of our Kotetsu is that we
try to make as few batches as possible
we will see later how we do it but for
now let's see a very interesting battle
sample
this is an example of the main event
with latitude and longitude this is
technically correct however it doesn't
have much value without a context
coordinate and only dot in the space but
when you provide a contest like a state
city postal code they become something
valuable and reach in one event with
this information is easy the problems
over when you have to enrich million of
events to handle this problem we create
geospatial intersects using DTS and year
tools and call them from spar SQL in
order to process million of events using
only SQL we are about to finish our
journey and now it's time to talk about
data exploration the first thing is how
to query data
one ring to rule them all but I don't
want to use the language of Mordor I
want to use SQL let's see how to do it
you see hive you can read from the sign
of data sources in the image some of the
data sources you set by let go
however with time I've had begun a bit
of solid for some use cases as a result
new technologies has appeared around the
high meta store in order to replace hive
the most important among them are Impala
press 2 DB and a spark and here is where
our idea of democratizing data coming we
want to query all our data using SQL how
we can do it using a spar tree server we
can read from all of our data sources we
only need to create the table over some
of the supported data sources for
example a DPS with Dec JSON s3 with
parkette Cassandra recive and once done
we can query data in a unified way using
SQL making joins between data sources
what is the difference between these two
create table statement the first one
uses high serialize and deserialize errs
and the second one uses a spar native
sterilizer in our test the second one
gave up up to 70% speed-up
as I told you before we we try to make a
few batches as possible we prefer to use
SQL first we have to create the table
over Sun of the supported data sources
as you can see enemy image is real then
the second step is the insertion the
sustainment is composed on to part the
salad when you can make queries and
joins over all your data and insertion
in this per pay attention to overwrite
and party T on keyboards in order to
append data without duplication we run
the query and apps we have a problem we
get 200 small files but why 200 the
reason is is the default value of this
property so we have to add something
more to our query we have three option
distributed by we will add one file per
day cluster it by we will get multiple
files because he's an alias of the last
option over so overall the indicated
columns and distribute by with certified
we will get only one file sorted in this
place by user ID but why a you sorted
file will be important the reason is
what is the most common is partying sort
merge join so if we want to make a query
between two table the first step is
going to be assault so if we have the
file sorted the join will be much faster
will change our query and we achieve our
desired result now it's time to see a
global vision of our architecture
on the right some data sources you said
by let go and on the left sunless portal
tools like super said buying tableau and
data science tool like rstudio Jupiter
Zeppelin or spark all of them connected
using the spur three server and the high
meta store for some people this is the
typical data science team other of all
creators that you want to cuddle but I
see them as evil machines that want to
destroy my cluster why I think in this
way basically that the scientists are
the main users of our architecture and
as everybody knows you sir do unexpected
things sometimes very bad things let's
talk about data scientists sins look
there are more than 3,000 small files
and as you know a small files are very
bad for big data I have already told you
how to fix this problem
heute queries usually we can find
patterns inside field queries for
example the same condition our relation
so in order to fix this problem we
should split the queries in a smaller
part and try to put two precomputed a
only weekly monthly to maths at all they
don't only make our query slower they
could also fill that is generating
instability in our cluster the solution
will be found case by case but in
general we should minimize the movie
data we have to filter out data as soon
as possible for example making adding
work losses in subset
making aggravation in subset or
selecting only the required columns for
the orchestration of our pipelines we
choose air flow in air flow we can we
can see our executed running or failure
tags and the most important our data
scientists can develop the data
pipelines in autonomous way they don't
require to the developers health so they
can explore all our data and when they
find something interesting they can
schedule the good recollection of this
data as we saw before they can they can
create the table and then execute the
insertion in The Wanted frequency hourly
only weekly all made using simple Python
code okay
but when we believe that we have the
perfect platform we found some problems
on one hand we wanted to try new
technologies but in the other hand
trying something new was very dangerous
because a lot of features depend on our
cluster and we couldn't afford to break
it all so since our cluster was built
mainly mainly manually
starting a new one was a very expensive
operation so we decided to address this
problem in two steps the first one
moving all the data front ad s2 s3 and
the second one automating the creation
of new clusters using a cloud break it
was a big challenge we have to make
thousand of tags in order to complete
the migration but we did it and we got
new capabilities right now we can start
a new clustering in less than twenty
minutes
women rate to Hadoop three and most
important we improve our experimenting
capabilities right now we can start a
when we need to try something new we can
start a new cluster in our development
environment with different configuration
and we get the decided configuration we
can start a new clustering production
regulate the traffic and also in case of
failure we can roll back to the previous
one
we finally arrived to our destination
and something wonderful will happen
thanks to our platform we could I start
trying new ideas any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
our data scientist developed this idea
within a week point to the problem with
your camera and we make all the work for
you in real time it was a video but is
not working I'm sorry the only way to
discover the limit of the possible is to
go beyond them into the impossible this
is not the end of the story we are now
working in a new wonderful ideas and now
is your turn
do you want to develop the future do you
want to join us
good talk here well what are you sorry
just okay and one question
well two questions the first one is you
say that you were using cassandra for
the duplicating events yes
did you try kafka streams for that
because it also provides the exactly
ones you want yeah no I we didn't try
Kafka's wins yeah it provides a sadly
one but the problem is as I said events
cooler right very late sometimes days
later so with Kafka stream is impossible
to make that because when you have 1
billion of even daily maintain this
amount of data in Kafka stream for 1 day
2 day 3 days is impossible so in the
past we try and others
lucien based on for example hostel casts
or but store this data in memory is
impossible and just I was wondering
which computer are you using yeah it's
an iPad pro yeah yeah because I'm Ali
nice guy so I have to use this this one
no I try it him in my in my company and
it's worth quarterly maybe sub problem
with the projector I don't know
yeah I'm sorry because they let this
light was very very nice but you can see
any transition so sorry
okay so ah hello and I think I I got the
the person should play well I mean it
was blinking a little bit but you did a
really good job with the presentation it
looked very nice I was I have to
question the FIR one is if you could put
the presentation somewhere so I can take
a look more yes yes of course I saw
their presentation with Pete so he's
going to be open okay and my real
question was could you expand on the
problem that you had with s3 and the
small files I didn't understand what the
problem was and how you fixed it
thank you yeah okay the problem is not
something about s3 is in general store
small files is not good because when you
if you have a hundred thousand million
of small files is worth because it's our
own trip it's time you need to read the
data you have to read the small file the
small file it has a lot of latencies so
there's a problem with a small file is
as default as I saw you in in the
presentation you will get 200 small
files and the the way to fix it in
general is to make the include some kind
of partition so in this way all the data
for some partition for example of date
of our is going to be only in one file
yeah you can see in the presentation you
have to add some some keyboard you can
use a distribute bite and is going to be
said you have to create a table with
partition table and after that use
distribute by and is going to be if he
said hi you mentioned you were you you
used Kafka instead of simple queue
service or kinases or anything else what
specifically was it about Kafka
secondly since you're running Kafka
how's the operational experience of
running your own Kafka cluster okay a
Kafka is wonderful our experience is
it's a fantastic technology is worth
very nice
they administrate a Kafka is really easy
so and also is wonderful in general I
can sew something better it's the most
stable technology in our estate in a way
stack do you want to know why we don't
use kinases or Kafka because my
experience wasn't like that a few years
ago when I tried it so it's just
surprising yeah any come people we
started with Kafka two years ago and
also with right penises but the problem
with enus eses is not possible to use
for the sample Kafka conet that is a
fantastic technology and also you can
have more control using Kafka a Kafka
streams of course is not cheap because
Genesis is good if you only need some
string you start using but when you
start to have billions of events it's
going to be very expensive compared with
Kafka
so if you have a big company it's a
better option to use Kafka in the point
of view of money but also in the point
of view of capabilities and how is the
operational experience of maintaining
your own Kafka cluster it was very easy
to operate Kafka it is a very good
technology in our spirit nice is good we
never had any problem with Kafka and
he's something difficult to say it about
other technologies
hello thank you very much I enjoy it
how do you secure the system ok signor
I'm sorry I I can't I can talk about the
security of our platform for for reason
of my company I can sir this one for you
so I'm sorry thank you very much
you said you solved small flies but
program by merging them into a single
file
how about writing performance I think if
output side is two rows such as chains
or 100 gigabytes only single executor
yeah of course yeah if you want to have
only one file the insertion time is
going to be a bit higher of course but
you have to think about a query time you
only write one time but you query data a
lot of time so we have to think about
quarry time so of course the insertion
is a slow work thank you
you